hello guys my name is Asher no and
there's a Java update available anyway
my name is achernar and welcome to dev
vlog number 11 of the Sparky game engine
so this dev vlogs really gonna just be
like basically me explaining my plans
for the next week or so
for the next month really I think
because I didn't really do much over the
last week as you know I was preparing
for the release which came out on
Thursday which was the 31st of March so
after that since Thursday I basically
haven't worked on Sparky like I've
checked a few things out and I've tested
a few things but I didn't think I've
added any more card or fixed any bugs
really so there's not really much new
that I can share with you guys but I do
want to show you a few things that I
noticed because of course I did release
it on I did release like the Sparky
March release on um on Thursday the 31st
of March so if we take a look at github
if you do just go to github.com for
slash the Cherno for slash Sparky you'll
see the Sparky repository we hit 300
stars which is pretty awesome so if
there's anyone who hasn't starred the
repository yet the first first thing you
should do is go ahead and go to the link
in the description and hit the star
button because because that's that's
very important but anyway um you can see
that in the commits that I had that I
made there was this barking Marsh
release which was a huge commit if we
look at the actual log for that you'll
see that 653 changed files with a
hundred thousand additions in lines of
code in two hundred two thousand four
and 144 deletions a lot of the additions
obviously just me putting frame image in
but there is a lot of code that got
written so it was very very huge you can
see there's like the there's even a hold
released nice thing and this was
actually made into an actual release so
if you go to releases you can say that
there's zero point one I'm calling it
which is in the March 2016 release which
is pretty cool so we release that here
it is there's a full kind of change log
here and some kind of more like release
notes and that's pretty cool so because
of that and one of the big motivations
for me finally doing a release was two
things first of all we can actually
start proper bug tracking so you can see
that people have been opening
issues over the last few days and we've
been closing some as well that's been
going pretty pretty good and then of
course pull requests now it's gonna take
a while for these pull requests to get
processed like as in I expect it's gonna
take you guys a while before you can
actually open up pull requests because
there needs to be a few things really
needs to happen for that first of all
you need to kind of understand how the
engine works and I expect that anyone
who is actually interested in it it'll
take you guys probably a few weeks
especially without me putting out a
video to kind of know your way around
the engine especially if you're kind of
new to C++ like engine programming and
OpenGL and DirectX but eventually I
obviously want you guys to participate
pull requests because I will accept them
and yeah I mean I mentioned in the
release video that is just impossible
for me to kind of manage this project by
myself so I would love people to
contribute but anyway all the code is
here so physically based rendering
directx and opengl old code uni is here
like if you want to I think sandbox
shaders advanced lighting shader and
advanced lighting got HD I'll sell at
the two PBR shaders
so you can see all the code for that
over here so that's that's out really
doesn't syntax highlight I show a cell
that's odd but anyway so that's finally
out there no no no I know there's a lot
of people were really interested in
physically based rendering and whilst I
probably won't do a video on how it
works for a while just because I don't
have time you can certainly kind of
start to dissect it and I highly
recommend you guys read the they're
moving frostbite to PBR paper it's about
120 pages and Sparky's Sparky's
implementation of PBR is loosely based
on it not really loosely it's about at
90% taken from there there are a few
changes I've made here and they're
mostly to stuff like roughness and
smoothness curves and a few things here
and there but it's it's roughly the same
see what I did there I said it's roughly
the same and roughness is uh anyway so
the idea is that
definitely take a look at that if you if
you were interested in that because it's
it's it's up there now and as you can
see I did like for example except I did
accept the pull requests from T G SM so
he's the first official contributor to
Sparky that isn't me who of course
removed a letter a that I accidentally
had in my shader causing it to not
compile for OpenGL
but anyway so thank you for that oh cool
so anyway that that's how that that
that's up there now so go ahead and take
a look at that everything should work I
believe the only thing that's not
included here is the actual if you go to
tools dependencies there's only the
include folder for FBX okay the
libraries for FBX which are needed by
spm build are not in the git repository
because they are over a hundred
megabytes and github does the github
does not allow files above a hundred
megabytes and in fact get in general
doesn't deal well with large files flash
binary files but github just straight up
doesn't allow it so I couldn't do
anything so you need to install the FBX
SDK it doesn't really have to be a
version a 2016 don't want to like 2016
will work fine and then you have to copy
the Lib folders into dependencies slash
FBX SDK slash leap and then you can put
them down because as you can see spm
build depends on where is it library
path yeah so like x86 slash release and
the input for the linker is like
additional dependencies here they are so
it needs like in this case Lib FBX SDK
- MD for the debug version and the
release version it seems that's probably
not even right I know that there's two
libraries as the debug and there's a
release version anyway the idea is that
that's the only thing that you'll need
to actually do yourself otherwise
everything should work fine and I should
probably extern this or like I don't
know I might have to put a little note
being like you need to download and
install the FBX SDK okay cool so the
question now the burning question on
everyone's mind is was going to happen
on the over the next week
and we're going to talk about that in a
minute one of the things that I want to
mention before we do that though is
people have been
playing around with Sparky obviously now
that is out there and kind of you know
doing some tests like building scenes
and then essentially checking out like
the performance of Sparky and then like
reporting hey like I do this and it
makes everything slow or I try and you
know I I built this scene and it's
running really slowly and that's fine
that's obviously great I absolutely love
that you guys are doing that but one
thing that I want to mention real quick
is that if I run when you're profiling
right it's very important that you
actually profile in release mode and I
just want to show you this right now so
you can see that just running sandbox
and DirectX 11 we get this scene
rendering at about seven to eight
milliseconds per frame sixth six to
eight I'll say milliseconds per frame
right which is pretty slow right and I
expect it to be slow as I said DirectX
is very very not optimized yet in Sparky
I'm doing some very horrible things that
I should definitely not be doing but
anyway the point is that is running
around 6 to 8 milliseconds right if I
just switch that up to release mode and
run it and that's all I've done or just
switch the configuration to release mode
and I run it first of all in it took
like a quarter of time but also you will
see that the frame time is now 3
milliseconds ok 3 or 4 so it's about
twice as fast
in fact as exactly twice as fast ok it's
taking half the time to render so that's
just a little heads-up for you guys that
if you are doing profiles and you're
reporting that like this is the same I'm
using this is the hardware I'm using
this is the performance make sure you do
that in release mode because I don't
really care about debug mode right debug
mode is doing a lot of things it's not
even doing it's not even doing all the
debug things yet but you can see that
it's significantly slower ok it's half
it states it takes double the time to
render frames okay so that's just
something that I wanted to throw out
there so that you guys realize that when
he walked profiling you should be
profiling with full optimization on okay
cool and that's what the release
configuration in Sparky is set up for
like full optimization and we did that
very early on I think one we were
profiling the batch renderer we did that
so it's got like full in lying of
functions wherever possible has got
stuff like internal like SSE
and floating-point you know we set it
like fast and really the whole compiler
setting is set to fast code rather than
small code or like compact code anyway
the point is it's very easy it's full of
polarization as well okay so that now
that's out of the way let's take a look
at what we're gonna do over the next
week or month so this is the Trello
board bitly falaqa Trello link in the
description I encourage you guys to take
a look at this because this is the
roadmap for Sparky you can comment on
issues as well and comment on things
that are going on and I will get them
I'm usually pretty responsive for
example you can see me like replying
here that's me on China golf you can see
me here applying here everywhere and
like I'm pretty active here because this
is I use this all the time like when I'm
working on Sparky I usually have this
open so this is what's gonna happen
right I asked you guys last time what
you wanted to see next and you really
didn't mind too much so I decided to
take the lead here and say that what
we're gonna be working on is essentially
the next big thing that I want to put
into Sparky is a level editor okay
because it's very annoying that all of
you guys went out creating scenes have
to kind of create it by hand like in
code and it kinda gets very messy and
also it that means that it's subject to
how you guys set things up right for
example you might create duplicate
materials and places and there's not
really much control I have over how it
actually like it depends on how you
write the code and you some of you might
be running slow code so instead of doing
all that and of course the major issue
here being that it will take off and
take a lot more time to code the stuff
up than to use a level editor I'm going
to just basically start working on a
level editor now a lot has to be done
before we can actually do a level editor
okay there are basically two two large
things that need to be done okay there
needs to be a civilization library so we
need to be able to obviously save the
level dot around into a format that the
engine can read at runtime and then for
the full list since I'm going to write
the editor in c-sharp WPF we need we
need to either write the like a wrapper
for the entire engines API in in C++ CLI
so that we can access the engine
is a shop or we can write a tool that
just wraps everything for us so I'm
gonna be opting for the latter method
because it's going to be absolutely
unmaintainable to have to keep manually
changing the CLI wrapper every time the
API for Sparky changes so anyway so CLI
generates generate a superboss CLI
wrapping code for the engine that yeah
so this guy's on the right track here
we're probably not gonna be whenever use
Windows forms we're gonna because we're
kind of trying to be more modern and WPF
is a little bit more powerful little bit
steeper learning curve but I've been
using it for a while now probably about
a year or so so I know how it works
uh-huh I would say I still don't know
how it works but um it it's I'm prime
kind of a cave-like familiar with it so
I will be using WPF and the idea is that
once we have that CLI generator up and
running we can start working on the
level editor so that's kind of the first
thing that needs to get done that's why
it's on critical now for the
serialization side of things which is is
kind of gonna be similar to the
Civilization series I did in Java it's
gonna be a little bit different they
obviously we can optimize a lot more
because it'll be written in C++ but also
like I'm gonna probably optimize the
format a lot more for that I do really
want to create a virtual file system so
what I mean by that is a like a VFS
essentially is here we go so like I've
put a little bit of a of a description
here and that pretty much outlines
exactly what I wanted to say right with
a VFS we can do things like just say
/res and then slash you know textured up
Angie and like essentially like when we
create mount points using the VFS it
will just resolve the paths based on the
mount point so basically like the engine
when it loads things from certain pops
those paths can actually get translated
into different paths when it comes to
actually loading the file so you can
kind of refer to it independently right
so basically what I mean is I could
write /res you know like slash Perez
last texture dog and J but really I
would be meaning like
you know it might be like /resources
slash textures slash textured or pan J
so that's what it could resolve to and
then obviously this depends on what
platform you're on because it might be
stored in different like in different
directories based on the platform and
based on like the texture compression
format as well because a common thing
obviously to do it would be like if
you're on different platforms and I'm
more talking about stuff like mobile you
might want to use a texture compression
format that is you know for that
particular device and so you might have
different textures to load and you can
kind of use the VF s to switch which one
actually gets loaded but the engine
everything refers to it as just like
that which is really easy the other
really important part is that we can
eventually support rating from binary
blobs what I mean by that is you can
have all of your resources packed into a
single file right and like I literally
mean just like take two bites and just
keep it pending them to the end right
and you get a big blob and that blob of
course you should you you still want to
be able to say hey files hey like I want
to read this file but then if you're
using a binary blob it will actually
just look up an offset in that blob
probably open a memory map to it or
something and then just give you the
data you want right so it's just kind of
it's pretty much like creating like an
asset server right creating something
that will like we can ask for an asset
on disk and it'll just kind of give it
to us and the way that it gives it to us
is the engine will take care of that
right you just say something as simple
as that and it will resolve the path
itself okay whether again whether that
be in a binary blob or actually some
folder right on our computer also if you
you know you can write stuff out like
data slash save dot that right and
basically you know the VFS will be like
okay you're in the slash data so I'll
might resolve that to being like you
know if you're on Windows to being like
app dot slash game name slash blah blah
right so you can kind of see how it just
makes everything a lot more simple
because obviously slash like this path
is Windows only and
might you know might be in like home or
whatever if you're on linux and there's
so many things so many things that it
could be right so that's kind of the
idea right and I want to do that that
shouldn't take too long I imagine like
the like not the binary blob stuff but
just them like the virtual file system
probably should take about a couple days
if I actually spend time working on it
so that'll be done quickly and then I'll
probably do the sterilization stuff then
the CLI generator then the level editor
so I expected these three things to be
done by the end of the month and then
the level editor may be might be
hopefully someone released in May like
at the end of May maybe that's kind of
my timeline for this very loose but that
is that's that so anyway thanks guys for
watching this episode this dev vlog if
you guys enjoy sparking you want to
support it and you you know the best way
to support it is actually I opened up
patreon but really the best way to
support it would be to contribute but if
you can't do that then you can always
become a patreon get access to code
early I'm probably gonna stay on github
for a while but eventually I probably
will switch back to fashion because it's
a lot easier and it's a lot faster for
me to use than github like if is like if
for some reason it took me like I don't
know two hours almost too damp to
download a fresh check out of this which
is just absolutely ridiculous whereas
this is just sort of my server but
anyway and version er actually does deal
with large binary files like the FBX
stuff perfectly right I can't even have
my FBX SDK here whereas I do have it on
version and version it doesn't choke
like it does when it sees live binary
files so in that sense version er is
actually better than get although it is
still not 100% complete but anyway you
can always support me here if you enjoy
this stuff you don't have to but it
certainly helps but yeah thanks for
watching and I'll see you guys next time
next week next Monday with another vlog
goodbye